what's going on guys this is Rob and we
are back with night terrors and we pick
up with one of the coolest characters
from DC Comics which is the Sandman
Wesley dots now two main things are
gonna happen when it comes to Wesley
dots number one he's gonna give us this
really really cool story about the
nightmare Stone and number two he is
most likely going to come back to DC
Comics and I'll explain how that happens
as we get further through this but what
ends up going on here is that dead man
who's currently in possession of
Batman's body because Bruce Wayne
himself is dreaming just like everybody
else he approaches Sandman for the
purpose of figuring out what he knows
about the nightmare Stone now the reason
for this is because Wesley Dodds has a
very close history with dream of the
Endless and for those of you guys who
don't know what the endless are they are
about as close as you get in DC Comics
to Cosmic entities the cosmic entity
concept is not really a one-to-one
between DC and Marvel they just kind of
do it in their own differing ways but
dream represents the very concept of
dreaming so he is in immensely powerful
but there is the dream stone that exists
and seemingly over the course of DC
Comics they've presented this idea that
the nightmare stone is a twisted version
of the dreamstone so who better to ask
here than Wesley Dodds now the only
information that he really offers is he
says at some point in the early history
of his superhero Antics he had basically
come across a ritual sacrifice being
performed by the ultra Rich who were
bored and delving into crazy Magics and
they were attempting to summon the
nightmare Stone and so when Wesley Dodds
jumped in and then saved the person who
was going to be sacrificed he basically
realized that person was part of the
cult that him sacrificing his life would
bring the nightmare Stone into fruition
because the rest of the cult leaders or
at least the members of The Cult had
basically consumed a kind of death
potion the problem with this is that
even after this guy takes his own life
and the rest of the cult effectively
dies the nightmare Stone appears for a
brief moment and then disappears again
now much like what we're seeing here
with insomnia the main villain of this
story this cult sought the nightmare
stone for the purpose of using his power
to basically conquer the world but
following its disappearance Wesley Dodds
had literally traveled around to the
most prominent members of the Justice
Society of America which is to say the
forerunners to the Justice League before
the Justice League ever became the
Justice League and in turn asked them if
they knew anything about this right
talking to Dr Fate Kent Nelson Alan
Scott the original Green Lantern anybody
who had dealt with magic or mysticism
but none of them had ever heard of The
Nightmare Stone so seemingly Wesley
Dodds was the only one aware of its
existence and so following that he
basically ended up departing and then of
course once he's told by dead man okay I
appreciate the help we got to get you
back in your grave his response is but
like this is the case I have to solve so
I'm gonna stick around with you until
this case is done having said that
that's likely how Wesley Dodds is going
to stick around in DC Comics there's
going to be quote unquote more unsolved
cases from the his early days he's going
to try to figure those out in the modern
era and he'll stick around it'll be DC's
test bed to see whether or not anybody
cares if nobody cares they'll cancel the
comic if everybody cares they'll keep
him around so if you love Sandman make
sure you read a solo comic when it comes
out but what we end up doing here is
basically picking up with Dead Man and
Sandman traveling to terrific Tech
basically the base of operations for
Michael Holt Mr terrific one of the
smartest men in the world if not the
smartest man in the world in DC Comics
for those of you guys who are new to DC
what you're going to learn is that when
it comes to like the smartest people you
have like Bruce Wayne Lex Luthor Mr
terrific it just kind of shifts around
from time to time depending on who's
telling the story so it's not that
dissimilar from Marvel but the problem
with this is that if you guys recall the
previous videos that we've done at one
point dead man had tried to jump into
the memories of insomnia this guy who's
instigating this whole situation in the
first place and he's only ever been
getting glimpses but what it's done is
it's created a bridge where sometimes he
he's unwillingly pulled into the
memories of insomnia and other times he
travels there of his own accord and this
particular instance he's effectively
pulled and he ends up finding out that
this guy was being subjected to these
kind of experiments right that following
the whole situation where he was exposed
to the Lazarus Reign which is to say
that whole Lazarus Pit situation Lazarus
Planet which basically granted different
people Powers around the world that's
really the long and short of it that
nobody fully understood how his powers
worked and in what really seemed more
like nefarious purposes than anything
else he was being experimented on
presumably in an attempt to better
understand how his powers work and how
they function but because the whole
event of Lazarus planet and the Lazarus
Reign being spread around the world was
part and parcel to the actions of the
Justice League during the DC comic story
where the Justice League died and then
eventually came back insomnia celebrated
their deaths but then was just totally
pissed off about the fact that they had
come back to life and they had come back
as their normal selves whereas he he'd
been changed and Twisted by the Lazarus
ring so it's really more of just anger
and Vendetta right it's really just that
simple now there is more to his
character than all of that and there
really is a whole reason why he even
became so Twisted in the first place but
before we get an answer ultimately dead
man is forced out of the head of
insomnia and then in turn he's actually
forced to sort of endure his own little
bit of a nightmare not a full on one per
se it's really what's called the
sleepless night so basically the
henchman of insomnia that because
insomnia can't really exist in the real
world for a prolonged period of time he
sends his own henchmen out are they
important no not really I mean they're
here and like they do some stuff but
like they're the least important part of
the story what is cool here though is
that once these sleepless nights make
their move the entire group is met by
the arrival of Damian Wayne now for
those of you guys who are new to DC
Comics if you've been around for a while
you know who Damian Wayne is bear with
me here for a second for the new folks
Damien Wayne is the son of Bruce Wayne
and his story is really really really
cool he was like the son that Bruce
Wayne never knew he had it's an amazing
story that we should actually cover
because there's some really cool stuff
that happens there but Damien's hardcore
right this kid is super intense so much
so that he overpowers these sleepless
nights and while he's not really capable
of like destroying them per se because
of just the level of power that they
have it is enough to bide some time not
only that this kid's been flying the
Baton ring which I think is pretty dope
right like a 12 year old kid flying the
Batwing it's kind of Awesome
I wish I could have done that when I was
12 years old I love it but the thing
about this is that once he rescues dead
man and he rescues uh Sandman in turn he
actually tells dead man get out of the
body of Bruce Wayne now for those of you
guys who remember the Batman tie-ins for
this this is that moment when Bruce
Wayne realizes he's possessed and that
dead man leaves momentarily he
ultimately does come back but that's
kind of the issue is we haven't really
caught up to the point where you get to
the end of the Batman uh to issue tie-in
where like he wakes up from everything
or at least presumably wakes up but the
thing about this is that when they ask
the question how in the world are you
awake well everybody else in the world
is asleep Damien's like well I mean
through the power of plot armor right
like I've mastered every form of
meditation in existence and so I'm
basically willing myself to stay awake
which I do joke about it being a plot
armor thing Damien could actually do
that right just because of the level of
training he has which in a lot of ways I
would argue actually exceeds the
training of Batman right but he is an
exceedingly capable kid he's pretty
intense right honestly I don't care what
line of logic they use it's just cool to
see he's here but what we end up doing
is basically jumping back to the
memories of insomnia and learning more
about his past now one of the things
that I hope you notice here is that the
dreams are almost kind of given to us
out of order right it's just these
glimpses that dead man gets and we're
not really given a kind of chronological
order here at all and presumably what
had happened is that when it came to
insomnia and After experiencing this
kind of Lazarus Reign he keeps talking
about these sort of Dreams he has or
these visions that he would have
whenever it was that he went to sleep
but then it started getting to the point
where anytime he closed his eyes that he
started to see things and so where he's
basically talking to what really is a
kind of Narcotics Anonymous group due to
the fact that he had basically tried to
attain medications and then in turn was
busted by the cops and because of his
past was basically you know told hey you
got to come to uh to an a meeting that
he tells them I can can never sleep he's
on coffee all the time he's popping meds
all the time anything he can do to keep
himself awake and so where this guy
right the leader really the the head of
the group starts telling him well I mean
there's something that you're going to
have to do here you're eventually going
to have to forgive the Justice League so
again it does kind of look like it's
potentially in a chronological order
that he in turn freaks out right like he
smashes the coffee pot takes one of the
shards of glass and then cuts his own
eyelids off along with just killing this
guy because the idea is that if he can
never close his eyelids he can never go
to sleep so seemingly that's how he
started to go insane and in fact because
dead man is here in his mind looking at
his memories he actually responds to him
directly and he literally tells him do
not go any further you won't like what
you see and so what's really interesting
is that dead man comes to this
realization that yes insomnia is looking
for the nightmare Stone the problem here
is that he's looking in people's
nightmares and he can't find it in
anybody's nightmares anywhere in the
world at the same time he cannot find it
in the real world and so that's when
Sandman says then there's only one
conceivable place that it could have
been put which is between the real world
and the dreaming world right the in
between and so concocting another one of
his potions right it's kind of special
sleeping gas he in turn sprays down
Boston Brand and Damian Wayne which
basically puts them in this kind of
place between sleep and awake and
they're able to access the in between
now one of the sleepless nights busts in
and like Sandman kind of tries to fight
this guy with like a sword he says on
guard and like that's cool but if for no
other reason than understand what was
going on we had to give him some kind of
context so the thing here is that once
you get to the in between Batman and
Damien really dead man and Damian start
making their way through here because
there really is no true north there's no
real true God per se but what they
realize is that insomnia is trying to
force his way into this realm and
whether it's just because of the natural
limit education of insomnia's power
meaning he affects nightmares and
affects dreams therefore he cannot enter
a place that doesn't really pertain to
dreams or nightmares directly or it's
some other Force that's keeping him at
Bay he just simply can't access this
realm and so once they get into
basically the house of horror in DC
Comics which kind of bounces around and
has a whole history we don't necessarily
need to go into it what they end up
doing is once they get in they're forced
to kind of experience this sort of test
right where they basically endure their
own personal nightmare for the character
of dead man it's the realization that
where his origin story was that he was a
victim of what was basically a kind of
hit and that the trapeze line was cut he
basically fell to his death much in the
same way that like the flying graysons
right the appearance of Dick Grayson had
died that his his lie had always been
well I died before I hit the ground when
in reality he didn't he hit the ground
and then he started dying broke every
bone in his body basically like the dude
was shot right and like every every bone
in his body is basically broken and the
guy's just sitting there struggling but
he had effectively lied to everybody and
so confronting that lie accepting that
lie and coming to terms with that lie
while Damien Wayne does the exact same
thing It ultimately results in the
manifestation of The Nightmare Stone and
so once they have it they can seize
possession of it now that's exactly what
the cult did the difference is the cult
tried to bring it into the real world as
opposed to traveling to its location
seizing it and then bringing it back to
the real world right so two completely
different things but now that they have
this nightmare Stone they can in turn go
forward and then use its power to face
off against insomnia what form that
takes I have no idea but with that being
said guys we're going to bring this to
an end if you want to get caught up on
night terrors make sure you click this
link to the night terrors playlist and I
will catch you all later
peace